[Musique]
alors ces maillots edwina donc en
activité principale c'est florist et
malou d'activité c'est agricultrice avec
mon mari sur cilaos manama petite
boutique à l'archipel des métiers d'art
et au niveau de l'agriculture donc
diversifié aussi donc maraîchage
lentilles et transformation de produits
pour le magasin m'a fait pas mal de
petits boulots donc passé avec les
personnes âgées avec les enfants ont
travaillé en tant que femme de chambre
en hôtellerie et à un moment donné
demain un souci de santé et il fallait
faire un choix
on avait une passion citer les fleurs
donc m'a dirigé à mater aller les fleurs
pour faire mon métier principal
fleuriste ou nous avait des proches que
la vie des terrains abandonnés
donc on a voulu bien mettre à notre
disposition pour faire les agricultures
dessus ou blessés donné de la valeur au
terrain au lieu de laisser en friche on
fait donc qu'on nous fait pas les fleurs
nous fait du maraîchage donc
m'appartient à moi c'est de faire
principalement les semis sous ses airs
pour aller au jardin pour monsieur et la
récolte cela me donne un coup de main
aussi pour le ramassage la cueillette et
tout ça au niveau de deschamps il ya
aussi la lentille qu'on va bientôt
commencer a présenté au mois de mai on a
là sur le terrain on a le chien donc des
graines de chia
on a fait un petit peu d'ail et
diversifiée en fait sur les terrains
pour l'agriculture
l'humidité des interventions de
formation pour la fft a donc syndicat
des agriculteurs dont me fais de la
formation floral - fluris c'est pas que
piquer des fleurs dans dans de la mousse
tout simplement
c'est aussi la créativité récupération
de matériaux
en fait c'est un moment de partage et
que nous créent ensemble des choses à la
demande et mais fait partie aussi des
membres de bureaux de la psc
l'association planteurs lentilles de
cilaos
le département a pour des subventions
pour le développement de la lentille sur
cilaos sans fonds dans une association
les difficile de faire des expériences
et les pour les avenirs en fait donc là
il donne à nous les subventions c'est
pour expérimenter d'autres façons de
cultiver et de ne pas utiliser tout ce
qui est pesticides dans l'avenir
[Musique]